oh the lamestream media reacted to the
release of the FISA memo with alarm and
wild accusations on MSNBC rather than
discuss the content of the memo they
were so concerned about authorship and
protecting Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein what role did the White House
in fact play in the production of this
memo we know how it played out several
months ago and Devon Nunez Nunez made
that midnight run here to the White
House who is the way Joe McCarthy is to
doing here I have in my hands a document
it's just something they put and we
don't even know who the provenance of
this document is it could well have been
written by White House staff people
let's get a response to that wild
conjecture and they by the way say Trump
makes stuff up dude it's like making
stuff off whole cloth at MSNBC I was at
the gym watching this like you've got to
be kidding me White House deputy press
secretary
Hogan Gidley here to discuss the
president's next moves okay you heard it
you know you heard that I didn't write
it
yeah okay well we've ruled you out
that's okay this is the one of the lines
of attack today that there was a
coordinated effort between Devin Nunez
and the White House to first the to come
up with the idea for the memo and then
to push for the release of the memo and
perhaps even draft the memo three things
come up with the idea for the memo draft
the memo and release the memo what can
you say to us tonight to the White House
coordinate on any of those three levels
we didn't come up with it
we didn't draft it we didn't release it
so that's three noes I can tell you
unequivocally that's absolutely
ridiculous and it just seems that that's
kind of a diversion of some kind because
this is very clear that the memo raises
serious concerns about the integrity of
the decisions made at the highest levels
of both the Department of Justice and
the FBI and Laura when you can take and
use the most invasive surveillance
techniques on American citizens that
should be serious concern to most people
where are all the civil libertarians
today in the Democrat Party I mean
apparently they don't care at all about
the Fourth Amendment anymore but they
used to care about unlawful search and
seizure which you know I guess Carter
page could make the argument that this
was done unlawfully not
in the statute but the Democrats you
know they apparently that's just out the
window but the dossier they wanted out
immediately
remember that had to be put put out they
didn't they didn't question it they
didn't source it it was out they wanted
they wanted all that stuff out but for
some reason they didn't want this memo
out I find that very curious but I mean
it's a double standard I mean when it
suits their their their pleasure they
want to keep it quiet this is something
that obviously is of deep concern of the
American people to use a Democrat funded
document that's clearly used for you
know it's a campaign Oppo dump to use
that and not tell the judge that that's
what you're doing when they're signing
FISA warrants that's very dangerous
there was another line of attack today
by the Democrats I'd like you to respond
to let's watch I'm not surprised that
the FBI comes out and says that this is
dangerous of declassifying this
information is dangerous endanger
national security so-called núñez memo a
four-page memo which by the way
threatens extremely classified
information and in dangerous sources and
methods of our intelligence community to
be frivolous with their identity or
roads that can lose to lead to them it's
always fun to see Nancy on a Friday
night what what is your reaction here
you're endangering national security
Jonathan Turley Tucker's show said
there's literally no classified
information or sources of methods in
this memo at all absolutely we didn't
redact a word actually by the by the way
and look it came out today obviously the
FBI worked with Nunez to try and
declassify some of these same sources
and and and and in methods and that's
fine that's what happened but I mean
it's absolutely ridiculous to say on the
one hand this is going to threaten
national security and it's going to take
down this government and people whose
lives are going to be at risk and then
when it comes out they say that's a
nothing burger which is it they knew it
ahead of time they read it people are
gonna die like you're saying that people
are gonna die and Hogan ghibli and all
the White House President Trump pants
you have blood on your hands I mean this
is what this is where they're going
right but they don't have a problem with
open borders by the way immigration
another topic that by the way The Daily
Beast just for fun The Daily Beast has a
headline out tonight we have to let
throw this up on the on the screen
Trump's White House goes weirdly silent
on the Nunez memo oh wait a second
you're here with us and I think Mercedes
has been out there sure is my mic now
working yeah what are we talking about
the but weirdly silent that's crazy
and by the way john mccain has tweeted
out a reaction to this he's not happy at
all what is gonna put that up on screen
the mccain here it is the latest attacks
on the FBI and Department of Justice
serve no American interests no parties
no president's only Putin's Hogan how in
the world can you see the text messages
that have come out from people at the
highest levels not the rank and file not
the people we respect and appreciate
their hard work but the the the top-line
folks who were in the Hillary Clinton
investigation with an obvious Pro
Hillary Clinton bias and an anti Donald
Trump bias and not be concerned
whatsoever with that the president get a
fire Rosenstein he fires Rosenstein is
gonna be a political firestorm i think
it's better to have Rosenstein stay in
my view well there's there's been no
conversation or consideration for firing
a rod Rosenstein I mean we know kind of
what he did he approved one of the FISA
warrants okay I mean I think firing I
mean my view of firing him is the left
is begging for it they begged for it
call me to be fired they begged for
Muller to be fired now they're begging
for roses see they have a new target
every absolutely and it's the weirdly
silent thing we were having this
conversation when the day they said if
you fire Rosenstein it's a
constitutional Christ we came out and
said we're not firing him and they go
well it still it cost Whitehouse mulling
firing of firing and Rodd moesel silent
no this would be I'm just gonna if I
ever talk I'm just gonna call you
weirdly silent that's good I'll rename
it weirdly sighs that's fine come on
Hogan have a good weekend gang so much